hi everyone welcome back we hope you had
a good break and we're able to enjoy
some of the snacks in your basket
uh we're really looking forward to four
talks from different researchers now
across groups in msr that cover a range
of different topics
and
each prese each
researcher will be talking for about 20
minutes
you can put questions in the chat
channel
which the researchers
will be able to respond to uh
during uh the talks but also we'll have
a q a session at the end
where you we can we'll have a live uh
question and answer with all four
speakers
so the first of our speakers is uh
deputy
and he's from the rl group in msr and
we'll be talking about efficient
neural architecture search
so passing over you over to you
now
good morning may everyone i'm very
excited to be here talking at the ai
breakthroughs event welcome my name is
devadiptaday and i am a researcher in
the reinforcement learning group which
is part of the machine learning research
area in msr redmond i am very excited to
be here today talking to you about
a hot topic in machine learning called
neural architecture search and our
latest algorithm
this is joint work with ctelsa
hanzang who john lankford rich caravana
and eric horowitz
before we dive in i will take a moment
to introduce myself i graduated in 2015
from the robotics institute at cmu and
my background is at the intersection of
vision planning and reinforcement
learning and controls
my journey in this topic started when i
was visiting john lankford at msn new
york about two years ago and we were
somehow talking about densely and i put
up the densenet architecture table on
the projector john immediately replied
that he had no idea how these numbers
came about and what to do about it to be
honest i had no clue either
and this is the usual black magic
involved in selecting an architecture
event today there is this process of
trial and error trying several different
architectures choosing magic hyper
parameters like learning rate learning
grade schedule
initialization which can be very
frustrating and also makes it appear
that only groups with access to large
compute can complete
not only is this a frustrating process
we also have massive machine learning
talent shortage in industry today
all these factors have led the community
to focus on neural architecture search
where the goal is for computers to do
this tedious task instead of us humans
before we launch into the details of a
specific method i would like to present
a very short overview of a rapidly
expanding subfield so this will be a
five-minute literature overview of over
500 papers
being published but don't worry
every nas algorithm out there has these
three components there is a search space
which defines the space of all
realizable architectures a search
strategy to efficiently explore in this
space and often coupled with this search
strategy is some performance estimation
strategy where you're trying to figure
out what is the performance of
architectures which you haven't tried
yet
just to be clear the central challenge
in architecture search is that function
evaluation is expensive sampling a point
is expensive because a point in an
architecture point is an architecture
and to evaluate an architecture means to
go train it on the training set and find
its performance on the validation set
in literature you will find two kinds of
such spaces the first one is what is
called as the cell search space or micro
search space where it is assumed that
there exists an outer skeleton like
dense net or resnet and the search space
basically consists of finding cell
templates that will be replicated as
many times as are necessary
this has
tended to be the most widely used search
space mainly because it is much smaller
and allows some human domain knowledge
to be injected via the skeleton design
the macro search space is of course
fully general and that is what you would
generally expect
to
encounter when you think of neural
architecture search and here we don't
have any outer skeleton and cells so the
number of architectures that you can
realize is far more people tend to shy
away from this search space because it
is very large
this field is so hot that in this
excellent continuously updated list of
papers maintained by colleagues at
university of freiburg i counted more
than 200 papers in just 2020. note there
are still more than three months left if
you are interested in nas and want to
learn more about it i will recommend
starting from this excellent survey
article which is also periodically
updated by the authors
the earliest paper on nas actually goes
back to 1989 from cmu but this
particular paper by baradzoff and
quackley in 2016 really reignited the
revolution
at its core the method is very simple
there is a controller rnn which samples
architectures and sends it out to a
cluster to get trained in paragraph the
results are fed back to the controller
which updates itself so that it is more
likely to sample high performing
architectures the update rule is the
widely used reinforced algorithm the
canonical model free rl algorithm
here is a concrete example of how the
controller rnn samples an architecture
it predicts parameters of layers layer
by layer such as number of filters
filter height filter width stride height
stride bit etc while this was a great
first start it took thousands of gpu
hours to achieve reasonable results on
relatively small data sets like c410
this next paper cut down the search time
from thousands of gpu hours to a single
gpu date far more practical
on both cepha 10 and pantry bank innas
achieved good performance by using
orders of magnitude less search time
the trick that might appear barbaric at
first glance is to use weight sharing
amongst all the candidate architectures
remember the great expense in nas is
training each candidate architecture
individually by sharing weights amongst
all candidate architectures and jointly
training all of them the cost of forward
and backward propagation is amortized
across all of them one might wonder if
this hurts since weights don't
specialize to their own networks but it
turns out that there are some good
multitask regularization effects since
weights have to be learned
weights have to learn to be good across
all networks that share them
here are some examples of rnn cells
learned by enos
some examples of cnn cells as you can
see the cells are pretty complicated and
unlikely to be made up by humans
this last work we will look at before
move out moving on to petri dish is
darts short for differential
architecture
unlike enas darts does not use model
free rl has no controllers and has many
nice properties
darts relaxes the discrete optimization
problem in nas to a continuous
optimization problem using bi-level
optimization if you have heard of the
meta learning series of work by chelsea
finn and others darts is exactly the
same bi-level optimization applied to
architecture search
in this graph nodes are tensors and
edges are operations applied to parent
tensors to obtain the next tensor say
you have three operator choices example
con 5 cross 5 max pool identity to apply
to a tensor darts keeps them all around
with weights over each operation at the
end of optimization it picks the
operator which has the highest weight to
connect two tensors this is how you
obtain a final architecture the search
process utilizes by-level optimization
which alternates between regular neural
network training and training the
weights on operators often termed as
architecture rates
for an in-depth
from scratch tutorial please refer to
this video
now we can dive into our method
published last new rips named petridish
we chose the name because we are growing
networks from small to big and the
network decides how much capacity it
needs automatically
there were a number of reasons for
growing networks as you will see shortly
it is a fully general method which can
also deal with macro search spaces it
naturally incorporates new data as they
arrive and exploits prior knowledge like
human design models which can be
especially important in production
scenarios
petri dish is inspired by gradient
boosting and directly searches the
pareto frontier or trade-off curve of
flops memory versus accuracy
petri disc is also inspired by the
earliest work on architecture search
from 1999 named cascade correlation
learning architecture
petri dish has three phases in the
beginning there is a tiny seed or parent
model from which such starts in phase
one candidate neurons are evaluated to
see if adding them permanently to the
parent model will help lower accuracy
will help
increase accuracy in phase 1 the
candidates are not allowed to affect the
original model's gradients and weights
using some tricks that i will detail
soon the candidate with the highest
weight is selected to be added to the
parent model
now let's look at phase one in a bit
more detail imagine you have a simple
model on the left you are starting out
with a candidate layer is evaluated by
adding them to the parent network using
stop forwards
solid black arrow and stop gradient
dotted black arrow lines stop forward
layer has the property that it allows
gradients to flow through but does not
allow forward activations to pass
through stop gradient has the reverse
property this allows us to accumulate
gradient
of loss with respect to the candidate
neuron without affecting the forward and
backward flow of information in the
parent model
if we decide to accept the candidate
then the stop forward and stop gradient
layers are replaced by regular
connections in phase 2.
to amortize the cost of searching for
exponentially many candidates we utilize
the same weight sharing trick you saw
earlier and jointly train all candidates
together here sg and sf refer to the
stop forward and stop gradient layers
from before
in order to select a sparse number of
neurons we impose a l1 regularization
penalty on the architecture weights over
each candidate and select the one which
has the highest architecture weight
recall we have three phases to organize
the computation on a distributed system
we organize these phases into queue or
pools phase 0 is a pool of parent models
which we are generating children from
and we will talk about how to we are
going to choose parents in the next
slide phase one and phase two candidate
and children are organized into cues
that are resolved by worker processes
every time a model gets trained at the
end of phase two it forms a dot on this
loss versus cost plot
we maintain a continuously updated
updating estimate of the lower convex
hull denoted here by the red line of
this scatter plot
since we don't know where exactly the
pareto frontier is we indeed we wouldn't
be having the stock otherwise we
maintain a small tolerance region around
it and only those models which currently
lie on the pareto frontier get to be
sampled to go back to the parent pool
the assumption is that models which are
currently far away from the current
estimate of the pareto frontier are
unlikely to yield children which will
lower the current
estimate of the frontier
let's see some results but before i show
you numbers i would like to address a
current crisis in nasa land we have a
reproducibility and fair comparison
crisis in fact it is nearly impossible
to compare algorithms against each other
due to differences in search spaces the
training routine that is used to
actually train the model hardware used
some people may use v100 some people may
use tpu driver version coda version
stochastic stochasticity and training on
gpus but the community is working hard
to establish standard benchmarks and
here are some links of standard
benchmarks that you can refer to
that we are trying hard to rally behind
so that we can build
reproducible fair
algorithms
keeping in mind all the previous caveats
here are some results on both macro and
micro search basis on macro search space
at the time of publication battery dish
outperformed baselines in the same space
using fewer parameters on cell search on
micro search space petri dish gets
competitive performance
on transferring models found on c410 to
imagenet petri dish on macro search
space performs competitively with event
cell search space without having any
domain knowledge injection into
architecture design
so a big question that you might be
thinking is auto ml sort is is neural
architecture search in particular salt
the answer is far from no
still lots of domain knowledge is
injected into the process tricks and
tips are needed for
particular data sets in order to be
state of the art we also need more
better benchmarks as you saw before we
are working hard as a community to come
up with them and major papers currently
are stuck on fifa 100 imagenet and
country bank these are the marquee data
sets that everybody reports results on
and we need to move beyond this
data set so that we are not over fitting
to them as a community
and a thing which is also shrug under
the carpet are hyper parameters it is
assumed that there are some magic
constant hyper parameter numbers which
are going to be used to train a network
once it is sampled by any mechanism
there is no fully general solution yet
but there are lots of useful successes
that nas has
achieved uh
one thing i would like to highlight is
that we have just recently released a
new pi touch based library on github
with a permissive mit license so that we
can address this fair comparison and
reproduce the eutectic crisis as well as
provide a turnkey solution to
non-experts who are curious if nas can
help on their data sets but are
overwhelmed by the fire hose of research
coming out if you want to try and ask
for your problem we encourage you to try
it out and give us feedback via pull
requests and github issues
and now i would like to thank you all
and open it up for questions thanks
thanks steven
great presentation
just as a reminder you can all continue
to post questions to all of the speakers
in the q a channel
for the whole session
so please continue to add questions
and speakers that have already presented
can answer those uh live
and then we'll have the the q a at the
end
so our next presentation is from super
mukherjee from the language and
information technologies group
and this is on efficient learning for
neural language understanding at scale
hello everyone i am happy to welcome you
to the microsoft research ai
breakthrough event this year
my name is subhabrata mukherjee and i am
from the language and information
technologies group at msr
today i am going to give you a brief
overview into some of our key research
themes
with a particular focus on resource
efficient learning to scale neural
language understanding models
is a joint work with my other team
members ahmet guccing sahar and wei and
a lot of wonderful work done by our
summer interns over the years
the language and information
technologies group at msr works at the
intersection of neural language
understanding information access and
retrieval and applied machine learning
our core mission is to bring intelligent
and transfer the ai experiences to every
person and organization in this world
this involves thousands of domains
hundreds of different tasks and
languages where the key challenge is
efficient learning and inference at
scale
but how much annotations do we really
need for all of these different tasks
in general if you consider so many
different tasks domains and languages
and the cost of human annotation this
easily results in hundreds of millions
of dollars
even though you may have the budget in
many cases you cannot see or annotate
this data due to compliance reasons
primarily dealing with sensitive user
data
in this regard our team has been heavily
investing in these four key research
themes
scalable learning how do we train
massive deep learning models for
hundreds of different tasks domains and
languages with limited training levels
and i will give you a brief overview of
some of our recent advances with few
short learning and weak supervision
knowledge distillation to compress these
massive neural network models to deploy
them in practice with fast and scalable
inference
multilingual transfer learning helps us
scale these models to hundreds of
different languages with a particular
focus on low resource ones
and finally interactive learning with
human in the loop for course correction
when the model makes a mistake
last but not the least we want to build
robust and trustworthy models that
provide fair and equitable information
access to all
in the upcoming slides i will give you a
brief overview into each of these
different dimensions
particularly focusing on scalable
learning and knowledge distillation
to address the limited label data
challenge language model free training
has been widely adopted in recent times
for various analytic tasks in this deep
and massive neural network models are
trained in a self-supervised fashion
over massive amounts of unlabeled data
and then fine-tuned on some
task-specific level data for the
downstream tasks
a number of large and massive
pre-trained language models have been
developed in recent times following this
paradigm ranging from bird elmo to our
in-house during nlg and the most
recently released gpt3
although these models have been widely
successful in obtaining state of the art
results for a wide benchmark of inelu
tasks their huge size is a concern to
using them in practice
with the most recently released gpt3
of a massive 175 billion parameters
although pre-trained language models
reduce the annotation bottleneck they
still relied on thousands of labeled
training samples for fine tuning on the
downstream tasks to obtain the state of
the art performance
in this talk we primarily focus on the
aspects of scalable learning from
limited labels and knowledge
distillation for scalable deployment to
address the aforementioned challenges
so let us first focus on scalable
learning in this we want to develop
techniques to obtain state of the art
results with the pre-trained language
models while using only a few
hand-leveled examples for the target
task
for most tasks like text classification
sentiment classification and intent
detection we have some amount of label
data and large amounts of unlabeled
samples to learn from
self training as one of the earliest
semi supervised learning approaches have
been quite successful in these settings
in recent times
in this given a language model called
the teacher we continue pre-training the
teacher model on the task-specific
unlabelled data using masked language
modeling objectives
this makes it aware of the domain
semantics and vocabulary
then we find in the model on some amount
of task-specific label data
apply the teacher model on the
task-specific unlabelled data to obtain
its logics
this we call the augmented data
this is used to train the student model
the teacher and student model share
parameters and the above steps are
repeated till convergence
there are also other ways of data
augmentation like back translation
leveraging auxiliary resources like a
neural machine translation system
synthetic data in the form of domain
specific lexicons that we can use for
distance supervision as well as labeling
functions as in snorkel style that can
be used to improve the model performance
in this framework and all of these
different areas remain an active area of
research interest in our group
while standard self training considers
all the unlabeled samples not all of
them are equally useful for learning in
this work we leverage bayesian deep
learning techniques to leverage
uncertainty estimates of the teacher
model
for selecting samples that are most
informative for the student model to
learn from
we do it by a combination of three
techniques
we leverage monte carlo dropout to
obtain uncertainty estimates of the
underlying neural network
thereafter we compute entropy to find
samples that the teacher model is most
confused about
and finally confident learning to
emphasize low variance samples for
training the student model
in this text classification experiment
on several benchmark data sets we use
board as the base encoder
the first and last column for each data
set shows birth performance when trained
with only 30 levels versus thousands of
levels for the fully supervised setting
our framework for uncertainty away self
training which is the bar in yellow uses
only 30 labeled samples for each class
for each task and obtains performance
pretty close to the fully supervised
word setting
this demonstrates the impact of
unlabeled data and sample selection for
self training
and few short learning
finally as we increase the amount of
labeled samples for each task the
performance of the model also improves
gradually
this summer we have been working on
extending some of the prior ideas for
structured sequence labeling tasks which
is more difficult than instance level
classification tasks
previous works a priory select a
curriculum learning method for sample
selection like either using easy
examples or hard examples to learn from
however if the model already predicts
samples with very high confidence then
there is little to learn from the easy
examples
whereas hard pseudo labeled examples
might be just too noisy
in this work we leverage metal learning
to adaptively select samples based on
their gradient and the impact to improve
the student model performance on a
health out validation set
now we shift gear and move to other
techniques to deal with limited level
data leveraging weak
supervision many real-world tasks
involve users and allow access to a rich
set of user interactions with the system
for example user utterances clicks in an
intelligent assistant activity is
performed within a software and so on
these user interactions can be leveraged
to understand their intent better for
many nlu tasks
in this work we consider some
task-specific label data and these weak
signals coming from user interactions
that are jointly leveraged to train a
meta model and domain model
the meta model helps the main model to
learn by sample curation and level
correction
we develop hydra with the following
features it can exploit signals from
multiple weak sources of supervision
like user clicks utterances and query
refinement it leverages meta learning
for sample selection as well as correct
and noisy labels
additionally to obtain a better training
schedule it leverages self-based
learning as a form of curriculum
learning to select samples by their
easiness to learn from
we apply these techniques to an
interesting application for early fake
news detection leveraging weak social
supervision
given just the text of the above claim
it is difficult to find out whether the
news is true or fake
however we can leverage the user
discussions and social interactions in
the thread to derive more signals as a
form of weak supervision to train hydra
while hydra uses all the signals for
learning at test time it uses only the
textual content of the claim for
inference
this helps in early detection without
any social engagement that typically
take a long time to accumulate
we apply this for fake news detection in
two popular fake news benchmark data
sets namely politifact and gossip cop
hydra shown as the top most curve
performs better than other state of the
art methods including snorkel also the
performance gap between hydra and the
other methods increase as you decrease
the amount of clean label data to learn
from
this is given by a low value of the
clean data ratio
additionally hydra learns instance
specific and source specific weights for
aggregating weak signals from multiple
sources
finally we come to the last piece where
i discuss on how to efficiently deploy
these huge neural network models in
practice
we do this via method called knowledge
distillation
similar to the student teacher training
in self training here we adopt a big
model like birth as our teacher it is
used to produce logics and hidden
representations on large amounts of
unlabeled data that we call the transfer
set
then we train a smaller student model to
mimic the teacher's logics and
representations over this transfer set
we perform a multi-stage knowledge
distillation operating over two
different segments of the data
task specific optimization by optimizing
the cross entropy loss over label data
and the mimic learning over teacher
logics and representations over the
unlabeled data with three different loss
functions
multi-stage optimization for deep neural
networks suffer from some typical issues
like catastrophic forgetting where the
model forgets information acquired in
the earlier stages
to alleviate this we propose method to
progressively update the model
parameters by selective freezing and
unfreezing of the neural network layers
to obtain the best performance
we perform experiments for both text
classification and massive multilingual
ner over 41 languages to summarize
our student model that we call extreme
distill obtains massive compression with
35 times parameter reduction that is 98
smaller than the birth teacher model
while being 51 times faster although why
it retains 95 percent of the birth
performance over 41 languages
extreme digital is already being used
for several of our products and services
now to better illustrate how such a
technique can bring massive
infrastructure savings for real life
applications consider the following
hypothetical scenario
assume there are 100 million users for a
particular application where the user
poses 10 queries per day
consider 5 workdays per week in a year
and average 100 millisecond latency for
executing a query by a big model like
bird and the gpu cost for using this
model per hour
now extreme digital brings down this
latency to only 2 milliseconds
if you multiply all of the above numbers
this overall results in 15 million
dollar savings in this single scenario
making huge pre-trained models
affordable for all
finally to summarize in this talk i
presented techniques to make nlu models
scalable and accessible to everyone
i talked about learning techniques
leveraging few short learning and weak
supervision from user interactions to
scale these models to hundreds of
different tasks and languages using only
a few labeled samples for each task
i talked about knowledge distillation to
massively compress these models and
deploy them in practice with fast and
scalable inference
we have ongoing projects to further
scale these models to more languages in
the world with a particular focus on the
low resource ones where transfer
learning plays the key role
in addition to this we have also been
recently focused on improving
intelligent user experiences with human
in the loop
this enables humans to further interact
with the system in free form natural
language to guide the system for example
given the natural language user query to
find all locations with names containing
a particular keyword the system
generates an incorrect sql query as a
response
the user can now step in and rectify
again in natural language feedback of
his earlier intent in order to correct
the system
finally as we are deploying more and
more of these ai services in real world
we need to be aware of its deficiencies
and shortcomings
in this respect we need to build models
that provide a fair and equitable
information access to all and does not
discriminate against any specific group
we have some recent work in this space
where we analyze gender bias in
multilingual world embeddings and how it
propagates via cross-lingual transfer
learning
we propose strategies to mitigate this
bias by alignment to gender rich
languages and provide recommendations on
how you should use multilingual word
representations for downstream tasks
this brings me to the end of my
presentation thanks a lot for your
attention and looking forward to meet
many of you in the upcoming breakout
sessions
thanks super
we hope you enjoyed both of those
presentations we're going to take a
short break now and we'll be back again
at 15 minutes to the hour so that's 10
45 pacific time so go away
take a break grab a drink and
we'll be back soon
hi welcome back we hope you had a good
break
so we have two more talks from
researchers now before we move into the
q a don't forget you can
add your questions to the chat at any
point during these sessions
so next up we have gina sue
who's part of the human understanding
and empathy group in msr and she'll be
talking about her work on population
scale studies of human needs
which was performed during the covid at
19 pandemic and has some really
interesting results and analysis and
implications
passing over to gina
thank you daniel for the introduction
miss gina i work in the intersection of
hci ai effective computing and human
health and well-being and i have this
interesting role as both a research
developer at msr and also a phd student
at the university of washington
and today i'll be presenting the work
that demonstrates my dual role here and
i'd like to disclose that this work is
currently under submission and it's done
in collaboration with tim ottov who's my
advisor at the university of washington
and eric horvitz and ryan white here at
microsoft
so many of the existing studies and data
sets of the kovi 19 pandemic focus on
the biomedical and
epidemiological
aspects of the case and fatality rates
including efforts in detection infection
propagation therapeutic intervention and
vaccine design
however it's important to keep in mind
that although we may not all be infected
by the coronavirus we are all affected
by the coronavirus
these challenges include societal issues
such as disparities
economic issues such as unemployment
psychosocial issues such as stress
anxiety and loneliness
and they remind us that even though
certain public health policies may be
effective in mitigating the spread of
the disease pandemic-related policy
decisions cannot be made on health
information alone
instead we need to identify and
understand the multi-level system of
human needs and the impact of the
pandemic and its associated policy
decisions on these needs in order to
inform how we can better respond to the
pandemic and better prepare for future
responses
so how do we go about understanding
human needs
a standard way to assessing needs is
through survey-based methods but they
can be costly and time-consuming to
conduct or to gain fine-grained or
real-time insights at large scales
other methods such as market research or
analyzing purchase behaviors can also
provide insights about human needs but
they're often limited to
consumer and commercial interests
e-commerce platforms such as amazon or
walmart or specialized service providers
such as talkspace for mental health or
coursera for education may have access
to large-scale real-time analysis of
user behaviors but they're often myopic
on to special needs rather than
providing a holistic view of many needs
and public data such as twitter has been
used to characterize human needs but
again they portray only subset of needs
that are externalized in public
on the other hand our approach obtains
signals about human needs by observing
everyday interactions with a web search
engine in this case bing
and in fact human needs are often
expressed and fulfilled through seeking
information or obtaining tangible
support or material items on the web and
web search logs provide a glimpse into
human behaviors in their natural states
at large scale from data that's already
routinely collected
across a whole spectrum of needs and can
be near real time with fine geotemporal
granularity
so our data set involves a sample of web
search interactions for the u.s
population from bing during the first
seven months of the years 2019 and 2020
this included search query strings and
the urls of the subsequent clicks from
the search results page
timestamp and zip code for location
and in total we had over 35 billion
search interactions from roughly 86 of
the u.s zip codes
to understand how human needs have
changed during the pandemic we developed
a computational framework to
characterize human needs which consists
of ways to categorize human needs and
then ways to detect these human needs
and finally ways to quantify changes in
these human needs
so first our human needs
needs categorizations were inspired by
psychology theories we were largely
inspired by maslow's hierarchy of needs
and that human needs can be categorized
into broad categories that you can
commonly see on the right
physiological and safety needs at the
bottom as your basic needs love and
belonging and self-esteem as your
psychological needs and
self-actualization as your growth and
self-fulfillment needs
and we borrowed from these needs and
focused on five broad categories that
can be extracted from web searches and
they are
self-actualization cognitive love and
belonging safety and physiological needs
and often in the context of maslow's
hierarchy of needs the needs are thought
of as mutually exclusive but in reality
people can be experiencing multiple
needs simultaneously so we illustrate
that by a ladder here
and for each of these high level
categories we further sub divided them
into neat subcategories
for a total of 79 need subcategories
across five top need categories
and those 79 need subcategories
typically follow the definition of the
needs and the topics they include which
are shown here
self-actual actualization needs are
about realizing personal potential and
growth through recreational activities
parenting or weddings
cognitive needs relate to pursuit of
knowledge and intelligence such as
online education or educational degrees
love and belonging needs are social
emotional needs such as relationship or
mental health social network or social
activities
safety needs
stem from the desire to seek order
stability and protection so for example
personal protection finance banking job
search unemployment and housing
physiological needs which are basic
animal needs
our
examples include food air drink shelter
and other body needs
so next we extract these needs from
search interactions
and a search interaction could be an
expression of needs in multiple ways
it's a direct expression of a potential
satisfier for that need for example a
search query for toilet paper with a
subsequent click on walmart.com could
indicate a purchase intent that
satisfies a physiological need
or it could be a direct expression of
the deficiency or satisfaction of that
need for example pandemic anxiety is a
direct expression of the deficiency of
love and belonging need
and we match each search interaction to
a corresponding need subcategory through
simple detectors based on regular
expressions and basic propositional
logic
and once we're able to categorize each
interaction into one or more need
categories we then aggregated them
across
geography
and time
and one thing to note is that we were
also inspired by max neef's human scale
development in that a satisfier in our
case this expression of need can satisfy
multiple needs at once therefore we
allowed each expression of need to be
tagged with multiple need categories
and we validated our detection logic
using human labels from crowd workers
for the top five need categories and
achieve the precision of 97 using an
example-based precision logic for
multi-class multi-label classification
now that we can detect and aggregate the
needs we proceeded to quantify the needs
to
clarify the changes to these needs
during the pandemic
and we took a common
econometrics method of difference in
differences to account for compounding
effects between comparison groups in our
case we accounted for yearly seasonal
variations by comparing this year's
needs against last year's needs so
matching january 2019 to january 2020
we accounted for weekly variations by
matching day of the week essentially
aligning the days of the week between
the two years
we accounted for variations in query
volume by computing the relative
proportion of the queries that expressed
each need
finally the changes in the expression of
need n between time 1 and time 2 is
expressed as this equation here
in our case t1 is typically before the
declaration of the pandemic and t2 is
after the declaration of the pandemic
and we use the logarithmic scale to take
advantage of the symmetric properties
and the effect sizes that this form
provides
using this approach we first asked how
did humans human needs change over time
we took the average daily needs during
the period between january 6 to february
23 as the
pre-pandemic baseline and dates on or
after march 16th to be post-pandemic
period
then we computed daily relative changes
in each needs which you can see on the
y-axis here across all days in our data
set which you can see on the x-axis and
remember with log base 2 scale relative
change of 0 means that there has been no
change relative change of one means that
the needs have been doubled negative one
means that the needs have been halved
and vertical dotted lines represent
notable events
at a glance all needs are elevated after
march 1st with physiological needs being
most impacted and to understand what
contributes to these changes we examine
the subcategories
so physiological needs were primarily
contributed by health condition related
queries around the first reported code
of death in the u.s
followed by toilet paper and health
measurement equipment purchases
reaching a peak shortly after the
national emergency was declared in the
u.s
and around the time of mandated
lockdowns we see an increase in
cognitive cognitive needs through online
education queries
self-actualization as well as love and
belonging needs slowly pick up reaching
a peak in april
and they're contributed by queries
related to cooking and online social
activities
finally after about a month since the
pandemic we see a sharp increase in
safety needs shortly after the first
stimulus list checks were deposited
obviously contribute contributed by
stimulus related queries
and state unemployment site visits as
well as purchase of coven 19 protection
gear
interestingly we see a second rise of
physiological and safety needs as
coveted cases start to rise again in the
u.s and early june
and this time around what seems to be a
reactionary increase in safety needs
happen a lot quickly after the peak in
physiological needs
which could be an indication that the
population may be more economically
vulnerable during this second wave
the next question we asked was which
needs changed the most and to do this we
compare the average daily needs from the
pre-pandemic baseline to the average
daily needs from the first four weeks
during the post-pandemic period
and we then sorted the need
sub-categories based on their relative
change between these two times
and when we look at the top 12 new
subcategories that increase the most
we see that the most of them are
physiological and safety needs mostly on
food health and economic assistance
and toilet paper purchase and stimulus
stimulus queries reached well over ten
thousand percent in increase
uh with up to seven times increase in
online social activity queries
when we look at these subcategories
beyond the first four weeks we see that
unemployment and food assistance have
not come back to the pre-pandemic
baseline indicating uh long-term
socioeconomic instability
online social
activity queries also have not returned
indicating a prolonged social isolation
on the other hand when we look at the
top 12 new subcategories that decrease
the most we see more self-actualization
and other higher needs
when we look at the subcategories
themselves we see a pattern that these
decreased needs are typical indications
of positive or future outlooks such as
wedding higher education job search life
goals and securing housing or rental
and it's worrisome that some of these
needs remain below pre-pandemic baseline
especially for job search which shows
that those that are unemployed may not
be seeking employment
so in general we saw exponential
increase in basic needs and troublesome
decline in growth needs
our next question involved understanding
how differing policies may influence the
needs differently
and to address this question we looked
at statewide shelter and placed mandates
specifically the start dates and the
duration because each state varied in
when they were in effect and their
impact on needs related to social
emotion and relationships
we looked at both short-term and
long-term effects of the mandates
for short-term effects we compare the
needs one week before and two weeks
after each state's shelter and place
mandate
for long-term effects we compare the
needs from the pre-pandemic baseline
with the last four weeks of our data set
so
around july
we found that earlier shelter in place
start dates correlated with more mental
health site visits and fewer queries for
online social activities such as online
games with friends or things to do with
family online
we also found that longer shelter and
place duration correlated with more
negative mental health experiences
and fewer wedding related site visits or
purchases
and this indicates that earlier and
longer shelter-in-place mandates may
have unintended consequences on social
emotional needs such as mental health
lastly we wanted to understand if there
were gaps between the needs that are
expressed on web search engines and the
fulfillment of needs that are reported
from other data sources
and we looked at two neat subcategories
unemployment and domestic violence
we found that unemployment related web
searches closely matched unemployment
claims reported by the u.s department of
labor
however there are some discrepancies
most likely due to people being confused
about how to file the claims
they have questions around eligibility
or requirements and they were being
denied and having to file the claims
i'll get again online
for domestic violence
many news outlets and research articles
have reported increased risk for
domestic violence due to increased
physical and financial and social
emotional stressors as well as increased
alcohol consumption at home instead of
at bars
disturbingly we found that domestic
violence queries decreased by over 20
percent um confirming many of the fears
that victims are unable to reach out for
help under constant surveillance by
the offenders at home
and also given that firearm access is
highly linked to fatal domestic violence
incidents the increase in firearm
purchase interests during the pandemic
raises an alarm
so these exposed gaps between reported
and expressed needs highlight
opportunities for further investigation
by experts in social work
so in summary i've introduced a
computational framework for quantifying
the effects of the pandemic on human
needs expressed through web search
interactions
we found that basic needs such as
physiological and safety needs were
elevated while growth needs such as
self-actualization were subdued
earlier and longer shelter-in-place
mandates may have unintended
consequences on social emotional needs
we also expose gaps between reported and
expressed needs prompting further
investigation into how to improve access
to these critical resources
so where do we go from here
we think that there's an opportunity for
leveraging changes and needs as an
indication for a level of psychological
and economic resilience and
vulnerability
as we have seen in how the population
responded to the pandemic differently
for different needs we need to
understand how a community can endure
social and economic distress and which
communities are disproportionately and
negatively impacted
we also think that changes in needs can
guide efforts in preparing responses to
future events and
providing access to resources
our analysis has demonstrated that
understanding the impact of differing
policies or identifying the gaps between
how the needs are expressed on the web
and how the needs are reported in other
data sources
can help prepare adequate support and
hopefully to reduce barriers and
increase access to these critical
resources and interventions
so for more detail that i didn't cover
today please check out our paper on
archive and uh thank you and i look
forward to your questions during the q a
thank you gina very thought provoking
presentation
our final presentation uh for this
session before we move to the q a
is from alec agarwal and uh he's the
manager of the rl group
he'll be talking about rl work and
research at redmond
passing over to you alex
um
yeah
okay uh
so um i'm going to be talking about
a bit of an overview of the various
ongoing research activities
in the reinforcement learning group in
redmond and this is um this is meant to
be a bit broad but
we'll we'll try to get into some of the
specifics as well
uh so just a quick primer and reminder
on what reinforcement learning is about
it's an interactive learning process
between an agent and its environment
uh where the agent repeatedly observes
um
an observation or state will typically
stick to the term state
it chooses one of available
actions
and
observes a reward from the environment
and this process repeats many many times
and the objective is to find a policy
a policy here is a mapping a function
that takes in a state and spits out an
action
and the goal of the agent is to find a
behavioral policy that's going to
maximize the sum of rewards it obtains
over time
uh so just to ground this in an
intuitive example
uh let's think about uh designing um
an agent that can do uh job scheduling
for azure uh so the world we interact
with looks like the population of
various job requests that come into
azure
our state would be some description of a
candidate job
our actions are
potential machines where we can schedule
this job and the reward might be
something we want to improve
uh we we want jobs to finish fast so it
might be completion time it might be
cluster wide utilization in terms of
some appropriate metrics like packing
density and so on
and we want to
really optimize the overall health of
the cluster over a longer time period so
the goal is to find a job scheduling
policy
that over time leads to
smaller down times better throughput and
other performance indicators are
generally being improved
uh the reason we are excited about
reinforcement learning is of course it
has a promise to transform just about
every
aspect of technology that we interact
with in our daily lives i already
hinted at potential applications to
network and computer systems through our
running example
we can talk about potential use cases in
healthcare whether it's about
personalized treatment regimes or
a variety of
mobile health tools to help us navigate
our physical emotional and mental
well-being in these stressful times
and finally there is a
a a great number of potential
applications in all kinds of uh user
experience optimization whether it's you
know traditional recommendation system
type settings
or intelligent tutoring systems while
everybody is getting uh you know their
education at home
and uh i'm sure each one of you can come
up with um other potential applications
that are uh
that are ripe for the application of
reinforcement learning
so it's uh useful to take a step back
and ask what do we need from
reinforcement learning methods
to be applicable to all these and more
and if i have to describe in a nutshell
i would say what we need a reliable and
sample efficient learning methods
that can optimize these long-term
objectives we have such as you know the
cluster health or the the health of a
patient in healthcare scenarios and
so on
and this uh simultaneous goal of
reliability and sample efficiently
entails a few challenges
so uh one thing we always worry about in
reinforcement learning is uh this uh
quantity called a horizon which is
roughly you can think about it as how
long the effect of an action lasts
and the longer it is the further out in
the future you have to
plan in order to really take all
downstream consequences of your actions
into account
and unfortunately the longer this
horizon is the harder it makes your
learning problem uh
in in that the number of samples we
typically require
to
start behaving in a reasonable manner
can increase exponentially with this
horizon
now in many problems you are used to
working with lots of data but in
reinforcement learning this this can be
a real issue uh because we don't really
perceive our samples as a data set we
only collect them by interacting with
the environment
and that means we learn about
undesirable behaviors only when we try
them out in the real world
and that can be a a big obstacle in many
settings
finally i'm sure many of you have heard
you know great presentations and
research articles about
the high variance and instability that
many typical learning methods exhibit
uh in the quality of the solution they
produce and usually all these challenges
are over and above some of the
difficulties we face routinely in
supervised learning relating to
overfitting generalization and and uh
optimization etc
right so um
these are
uh
some of the things we have to worry
about if we want a reinforcement
learning to be applied in the real world
and
um in our group here we
do think about all of these challenges
of course i don't i don't have nearly
enough time to go into depth on all of
those
so our plan for today uh i want to give
you some uh technical substance so we'll
do a bit of a deep dive into one topic
of imitation learning
and then i'll go zoom out and give you a
quick overview of many other directions
that we are currently pursuing
so imitation learning is a subfield of
reinforcement learning which um stems
from the realization at least the
version of it we're going to talk about
today
that in real world uh applications uh we
usually don't start from uh scratch we
don't uh you know wake up one day and we
say oh i have this problem and i'm gonna
solve it by using reinforcement learning
directly it's quite typical that
practitioners have maybe tried other
approaches to solving the problem before
uh
perhaps uh by heuristics or by using
supervised learning or other approaches
and uh while these approaches
you know got to a a reasonable point
at some point the improvement stops and
they want to go further using
reinforcement learning
but these existing
approaches can provide us
with reasonable baselines
that do something meaningful in the task
at hand so let's let's think about some
examples
suppose we were trying to design a
reinforcement learning controller for an
indoor greenhouse
then
um
a pretty good starting point is actually
just a rule-based policy that you might
create by talking to uh domain experts
on indoor agriculture
uh if you're trying to design um
an autonomous driving agent this is
really hard because we have a number of
um
apart from you know driving well we just
have a a vast number of safety
constraints we need to take into account
and uh enforcing all of them
simultaneously can be hard but if we
take individual ones like okay you
should you should stop at a stoplight um
you should follow speed limits you
should follow the lane and so on these
are um you know we already see some of
these things in commercial cars uh
pretty broadly and it's
reasonably uh possible to have
controllers that are
designed for individual safety
constraints satisfying them
simultaneously is what's potentially
challenging
similarly in you know the
scheduling type example i talked about
before what we often have is
we have a number of quality of service
type agreements that we provide to the
customers and we need to
perform good on all those metrics
and again it's often easy to do well on
an individual metric but not on their
entire combination
but in all these settings what we see is
we can have
multiple
baselines such as for individual safety
constraints
they do something reasonable
but don't solve the overall problem well
and also different
baselines might work well in different
situations
and in this way they provide very useful
domain knowledge that we can use uh to
potentially accelerate the reinforcement
learning process
um
and this is the intuition we try to
leverage in the area of meditation
learning
uh so the first thing is uh we we do is
pretty common in all of machine learning
we
think about spreading the learning
process into training and test phases
and we leverage these baseline policies
often at training time to guide the
exploration
and if you know you can have the
baselines available united testing time
then we can continue to use them into
test
and
the way you can use these baselines is
to basically provide examples of useful
behavior
such as
having some basic strategies to prevent
the crops from drying
or um
getting some candidates of safe actions
in uh safety critical situations and
similarly
in the um
in the quality of service example
[Music]
okay so um there are many situations uh
where we have these um available
baseline policies how do we use them
let's uh start by thinking about what
what can we do when we have only one
baseline and this has been a very well
studied er ada in reinforcement learning
and a rough caricature of how we go
about
behaving here is um
so let's look at the caricature on the
right
there's a reinforcement learning agent
that is acting in the world and it
produces a produces a sequence of
interactions denoted as the
states that were observed the actions
that were chosen and the rewards that
were obtained
and it then presents this interaction
log to this baseline policy and the
baseline policy might tell oh i would
have taken maybe a different action than
the one you took for
state s1 and s2 and so on
right and now given this data
for instance the simplest thing we can
do is to just take
the
actions we've been provided by the
baseline as labels
and try to solve a supervised learning
problem to behave more like the baseline
and this is indeed a well studied idea
in the imitation learning
field
and works well if the baseline that you
that you've received is a reasonably
good policy
and at msr
we do have a lot of work here in this
area um across the different across the
different labs not just in redmond but
also in montreal new york cambridge and
so on uh including some of the first
algorithms to some of the
state-of-the-art approaches
but these are all only
uh catering to the case of a single
baseline and often requires a single
baseline to be quite good
so let's ask what what can we do going
back to our original question when we
have multiple baselines and
all of them are individually quite
suboptimal and different some optimal
baselines work well in different
situations
basic conundrum is when the learner is
in a state and needs to decide what to
do it might receive conflicting advice
from different baselines and it needs a
way to reconcile them
uh so in a recent paper uh
joint work with shingan chen and andre
kolabov on the team what we propose is
um we're gonna try and figure out
uh in any given situation what is the
best uh baseline meaning which is the
baseline policy um
that produces the best behavior
and we'll try to follow its advice
of course doing this is non-trivial
uh but also because each one of these is
individually suboptimal we will not just
stick to copying them we will do some
active exploration ourselves to um to to
find uh better behaviors and improve
upon these baselines
and uh the precise way we do the of
doing this we describe it in our paper
through an algorithm called mamba which
for which first tries to
constantly estimate the quality of each
baseline policy at all the states the
learner is listing
and this
quality estimation
[Laughter]
uh
uh
[Laughter]
um
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
just takes a couple of steps and it
falls down and just because this
and then
um
our algorithm mamba on the other hand
uh
takes off
and keeps going on and on and on i'll
point out in this particular experiment
you are actually using just one baseline
policy so this is
primarily showcasing that the
additional exploration that mamba
engages in really
lets it significantly outperform the
baseline policy and um
improve upon existing imitation learning
even in cases
where existing mutation learning uh was
known to do quite well
so for more details and experiments
about how we uh also leverage multiple
baselines in a
meaningful manner i encourage you to
take a look at the paper the archive
preprint is included here
but in the interest of time i want to
zoom back out
and
point out that there are many other
challenges we worry about in
reinforcement learning
whether it's about sample complexity
safety constraints a variety of
adversarial perturbations
uh or just you know robustness issues
due to distribution shift and so on
and we we we do worry about all of these
and do uh research actively on topics
ranging from exploration and
representation learning uh batch
reinforcement learning where there is no
active interaction with the environment
uh notions of adversarial robustness for
reinforcement learning and so on
and unfortunately i don't really have
time to get into all of them but i do
want to highlight a few other
areas of work
so uh one of the very successful ways uh
of late of improving the sample
complexity in supervised learning that
we see is by learning generic
representations that can then be applied
and fine-tuned for respective tasks
given that we are always worried about
sample complexity in reinforcement
learning it would be natural to try and
do the same here
and the hope would be that we can
use again like in supervised learning
use this uh representation learning idea
to successfully generalize across tasks
as well in reinforcement learning
whether we are thinking about the
variations small variations of a task
such as levels within a game
whether we are worried about uh related
tasks uh such as maybe two different
games in the atari suite or
you know even transferring from atari to
progen and the most ambitious and
desirable would be if we can use this in
a simulation to reality transfer type
approach where we maybe train the trendy
representation using lots of data
in a simulated environment and
then use it to have sample efficient
deployment onto a physical robot
so we've been
working in these areas
also
you know spurred by some recent work in
the group on
uh basic uh
neural net architectures to better
integrate transformers into
reinforcement learning and um a lot of
ongoing work on how to leverage that
for better representation learning
uh
since i mentioned um robotics there we
do have a a bunch of
interesting on
going names where we are
trying to apply some of the
reinforcement learning ideas to uh
physical systems uh whether it is um so
this is a pretty fun application uh you
know um azure data centers um
would love to automate a bunch of tasks
uh related to maintenance whether it's
about flipping uh circuit breakers
uh replacing faulty hard drives uh
faulty cables things like that and can
we automate some of these using
reinforcement learning
or
completely differently um if you want to
have a sail play and do autonomous
soaring without any um
uh human control and without any more
motorized support how do you do that
um so for more details um again um you
know i have happy to answer any
questions in q a or uh for those coming
to our group session tomorrow definitely
you know we'll go more into the details
of these
uh one final thing i wanted to highlight
was a lot of the reinforcement learning
research we see the domains are very
visual right so
it's natural to ask what reinforcement
learning should look like if our inputs
states and outputs actions are both
expressed in natural language matthew
has connect one of the researchers on
the team has been leading up this effort
on applying reinforcement learning in
text domains which obviously evokes
conversation
as an application
but simulating conversation is hard so
we study these things in
interactive fiction games which you can
think of as something like doom but
where you only see the description of
the screen rather than the photo of the
screen
and this contains a lot of challenges of
course we have to deal with enormously
complex
input at output spaces now and on the
output the action side is really
challenging but we also have to worry
about how to integrate things like
common sense reasoning and knowledge
representation into reinforcement
learning now and there's been some
really exciting work ranging from basic
platform development to uh agents that
folks from the group have been involved
in
okay so um coming back to a high level
as
in at a very high level we are you know
really excited about trying to bring the
promise of reinforcement learning into
the real world and we worry about all
the challenges we need to address to do
so whether it's about
improving video by leveling domain
knowledge as we saw in the mutation
learning example
whether it's about learning cue from
queues beyond explicit reward feedback
which is particularly vital in
representation learning type tasks
and certainly incorporating explicit
rewards as efficiently as possible which
is um kind of the topic of exploration
that i didn't really talk about today
but many of us care about
uh there's this url where you can go and
learn more about the team and
the members of the team and uh are
interested etc
and yeah look forward to answering um
any questions in the q a panel
thank you
thanks alec great presentation
so we have another short break now
for five minutes we'll come back at half
past the hour so it's 11 30 pacific time
and we'll then move into q a panel
session with the four speakers
so continue to put your questions in the
chat
and uh we will ask those questions
throughout that session
so we'll come back in five minutes
thanks
great welcome back and uh once again
thank you to all of our poor speakers
for their presentations just now so
we've got a panel session uh where we
can ask q a to uh
each of the speakers um
and i'm going to start off uh by us
asking gina a question
uh so this came through the chat from
maggie
and was related to
um
the the causal
understanding or causal reasoning you
can do from your data
and perhaps
do you think that employment
seeking
may be reduced because of employment
benefits and sort of more broadly
causally related questions like that
have you been able to
kind of find answers to those types of
questions from your data
yeah thank you for uh for a great
question so in terms of the causal
inference so this analysis that we've
done uses difference in differences
approach which um
has criticisms um that it's not uh
it's not it cannot make any causal
conclusions
so
with this current work we have not we
are not claiming any causal
relationships um but we are working on
leveraging some of the
um
some of the um techniques for causal
inferences to make those connections so
um it's it's coming we're working on it
i think it's it's possible but uh this
work definitely doesn't has that
limitation
um and in terms of the employment um so
what our goal was to really paint a
broad picture of needs um understanding
the fact that we're not experts in any
one of these you know subcategories or
categories of needs employment
being one of those things that we're not
experts in um but i did look in uh other
research areas just to try to understand
the landscape of why i'm seeing the kind
of
data that i'm seeing you know
unemployment unemployment going up um
and then employment job search uh going
down and
many other people have uh kind of
studied labor force issues during the
pandemic including you know kind of the
older generations they're retiring early
therefore they're not seeking jobs
other people have
you know anecdotally attributed things
to the people taking advantage of the
unemployment benefits so um i think
there are questions out there that uh
experts in this area can answer
certainly we
our goal is to try to raise these issues
and and bring
hopefully that we can actually
collaborate with people that are experts
in these fields and try to answer these
questions in more detail but yeah
unfortunately we
we don't have that expertise in-house i
think we have to go outside in order to
answer those kinds of questions
that's great and another question
from tom
covet is a particularly extreme example
of an event event
um
could you
explain more about what you've been
thinking about how such analyses could
be used in other cases maybe other types
of events whether extreme or not
and and you know what how you might have
to adjust your techniques if um these
events are more
uh localized or shorter
yeah definitely uh we have another big
event coming up in november it's the u.s
election um i think people have studied
the previous election and and they have
seen
uh impacts of the election on people's
heart rates mental health and other
kinds of things so certainly uh we can
do this for the election um
there are other interesting things uh
like daylight savings for example and
its impact on people's you know
cognitive functioning
um and and we can actually see through
people's search interactions or any
other other kind of telemetry through
services on on the the changes in how
people interact with these systems
because of that one hour difference so
that would be another thing that would
be interesting to look at certainly
things like
you know super bowl or
local disasters we can look at i think
the limitation is
on
right now we are able to get data at the
zip code level but
um the really interesting questions that
we want to be able to answer is by
combining
search interaction data with other
other external data sources like the
census like who are the people that
we're actually gathering this data for
and what can we what can we
understand and how do we explain the
data that we're seeing through kind of
the demographic information that that's
external to the bing search data um and
and that becomes the the limitation
right like for things like local
disasters you need to start to
understand like what are the available
local resources that you have for the
population that you're studying and and
those those things are just harder to uh
get access to
but if you have that information that i
think it's certainly applicable
great thanks
um moving on to
alec and subo you both talked about
ways of
learning
self-supervised learning so whether it's
student teacher methods or imitation
learning from a teacher to a student
what are your thoughts on the
limitations potentially of of those
approaches
maybe exaggerating biases so if a if a
teacher has a bias will that be passed
to a student um is the same true in
imitation learning and does mamba
perhaps help address some of those
issues or alleviate them at least
um so yeah what are your thoughts there
okay
so um you know a lot of um i guess a lot
of little sub questions in that question
so let me let me start by talking about
um
imitation learning and uh it's uh you
know the role of biases there so
you know absolutely
uh
true that you will
reflect the biases of the teacher
when you
when you're trying to build on
supervised learning enterprise learning
at its core uh suffers from the same
issue
um without
kind of building in
um some guardrails for fairness into the
underlying supervised learning
techniques we are using but that's also
a plus because we are using the
supervised learning techniques where
people have been working quite a bit
about
incorporating fairness considerations so
we can hopefully uh leverage some of
those ideas uh much more directly
but also there is the nice aspect in
some of these approaches in particular
like mamba because they're trying to not
just copy the baseline but really
improve on the teacher um
if at least the reward signals you have
are such that they
prefer
uh the less biased behavior
overall uh then you can hope that the
agent might discover them there is there
isn't really no way of
saying at the moment that the agent will
discover them for sure
um
but they're not at it um of course you
know they're like building building
reward functions that will capture
um or down player bias
itself is
pretty tricky in general
um so i don't want to somehow
i plan of uh you know making things less
biased just
down to the reward design problem
because that's not really solving it
either so so in you know in short we are
definitely not
uh
you know actively addressing that
problem at the moment
um and it might be an interesting uh
direction to pursue
okay thanks alec with regards to natural
language understanding we see that
sample selection plays a very important
role so we really kind of need to know
which are the instances on which the
teacher is confident on versus not so
confident on
that was our kind of main or core idea
behind this uncertainty of our
estimation where we kind of leverage the
low variance samples that are
coming from the teacher
that is the ones that they're most
confident about and only passing them
through the student
so
obviously in this process we do prune
out some of the noisy predictions from
the teacher and the student model is
able to perform outperform the teacher
in certain cases but yeah we also do
pass on some of the biases where the
teacher might have over fit to the
student
and in these cases as alec pointed out
we need to build other guard regard
rails regarding some kind of semantic
consistency constraints
or other kind of consistency constraints
based on the task that we are going to
solve in hand
great thanks
um
a similar or related question from eva
about the one of the charts you showed
in your presentation about lower gender
bias in languages
that have different words or
grammar for different genders
such as spanish
could you explain more about that uh the
evo is wondering
if you might expect that biases would be
larger in such a situation
okay so daniel i think that question
might have been for me yeah i was
talking about yeah
so in english like you have two genders
and in spanish you have three genders so
in most of the gendered languages what
we do in our work is
we project the semantic representations
into different gendered subspaces
so as you have more number of genders we
are able to kind of tease apart these
different biases that are
geared for different languages
for example if you had to take
language like for example say german
which also have more than two genders
and if you are to kind of do some kind
of transfer learning where you are
projecting the semantic representations
to
english which have kind of two genders
then you
kind of combine the biases that are
coming from multiple genders to only to
you
two principal units uh principle
directions on the other hand if you had
to project them to spanish
then you would see the different biases
on the different principle components
like three principle components more
clearly so that is i think the core idea
of projecting uh semantic representation
to different gendered subspaces where we
see that the bias decreases as you
project them to a language containing
more uh directions for the different
gender subspaces
great thanks
um and so uh moving back to definitely
sorry for that um
there was a question in the chat for
from tom about the
contrast between uh neural architecture
search and mammal
uh
so just drilling into that a bit more um
personalization is obviously a huge
thing in in machine learning you want to
ideally have models that are adapted to
specific individuals
do you have any could you share more
about any work you're doing in terms of
personalization of models and then
how that might be done efficiently for
instance if you wanted to adapt an
architecture of a model on a device and
not
shared like not do that in the cloud or
not do that
where you need to share data across um a
network or devices
yeah absolutely yeah that's a great
question um so uh one uh
the recent algorithm that we just uh
proposed and for which is also now in
archive our platform which is getting
shortly released and already on github
one nice property that we try to pay a
lot of attention to is this ability to
do better to frontier search where you
are so often times what happens in the
real world you don't care about
performance at a particular number of
flops or multiply ads or memory uh
occupied by your architecture only you
care about the entire trade-off curve so
that imagine you are serving you are
doing you you have a web service and
your web service has access to let's say
um
uh cloud gpus which are pretty um
big right like you know you have like
you know access to v100 gpus so there
you can have very easily like you know a
very nice like 300 megabyte model which
you can load and serve very fast uh but
uh but for reasons of like you know cost
and efficiency even there you may want
to like lower your bill because the v100
costs a lot more per hour than let's say
like you know an old m40 or even cpus um
and the other thing is you may want to
trade off what you want to do let's say
on the cell phone or on device or on iot
edge versus what you do on in the cloud
and and depending on you and there's a
and there's this really nice spectrum of
uh constraints that can come in on
memory uh flops etc and ideally you
would want an architecture such
algorithm to not just give you a single
point answer that this is the
architecture you use if you have a v100
but this is the architecture that you
might use if you have let's say an
iphone grade cell phone or this is the
active on which you want to do things on
device and and here's the trade-off
right like look an iphone grade device
will never have like you know the
accuracy um that maybe you will be able
to get on
a v100 with a very large network right
and uh but you may be able to see like
how much of that is acceptable to you
and trade off um in one search
alone but you you run
our hope is that you you take for your
data set you run petri dish and you come
up with a gallery of models and and then
you can uh choose which one to deploy
where without having to run search again
and again for every constraint so that
idea of directly searching the pareto
frontier is is a is a what we believe is
a very powerful thing to have in a
feature to have in the search algorithm
great thanks
um a question for alec uh so a lot of um
rl is is done in simulation uh
especially you know when you think about
safety critical scenarios you might need
to simulate those uh for certain reasons
but can you talk about uh
what you think are the sort of
challenges of moving from simulation to
the real world and and what the
differences are
limitations of simulation and advantages
of it
yeah um that's an excellent question so
uh you know
uh hit the nail right on the head uh
there's uh
obviously lots of
challenges that arise when trying to do
reinforcement learning directly in the
real world um in safety critical
settings um which is why we don't
see that as something happening uh every
day
you know and uh
certainly uh starting from simulation
and trying to do
uh simulation to reality transfer is uh
is is a natural thing to do there and
you know the one of the ways people
uh try to guard against um running into
unsafe situations there is by doing
a lot of basically perturbations to the
simulation to to make sure that the
agent is trained in environments
uh
that that that give it sort of robust
coverage against simulation errors right
so uh there are tricks called things
like domain
randomization
uh you might imagine that
opening a robotic agent in simulation
you
make sure you perturb environment
variables like
uh friction and
how contact forces behave things like
that
you know
things like um
imitation learning to again provide
some viable candidates for safe behavior
and also thinking about actively
incorporating constraints into
reinforcement learning algorithms which
is something there's been increasing
amounts of recent work on
as well as reasoning uh robustly from
offline data that we've collected which
basically is its own kind of simulator
are are all very important techniques
that are being increasingly developed in
this area um that said
you know
ensuring safety during training and
reinforcement learning certainly remains
remains an ongoing challenge for the
field um and um something we very
actively think about and have been uh
you know putting papers out on uh
even even very recently
great
thanks uh another question coming back
to gina uh na young was wondering if you
could elaborate a bit more about the the
propositional logic um sub
categorization of the the needs that you
did and and
uh
you know the process the yeah how did
you do that sub categorization and the
process to get there
um you'll be surprised it's so simple
um
it's it's just simple regexes
and
patterns that we identified that are
that would fit into each of the
categories so actually i didn't discuss
this uh too much in the talk but for
each kind of a high level category let's
take unemployment for example there
there are two kinds of matches we could
do
um so we had a list of unemployment
sites like the government sites each
state had um different sites that people
can go to
apply for an employment so we took kind
of like the the base domain url and try
to match the the subsequent clicks to
the domain url so that's one way of
doing it
another way to look for unemployment
signal is to to look at the query string
and see if they have mentions of job
application or
unemployment you know being laid off or
things like that
there are other things that are more
purchase related so
toilet paper for example like i said you
have to type the things that you are
looking to buy
but also it has to be followed by
a clicks into one of the e-commerce
domains so we had a list of uh somewhere
around 61
domains that popular domains that we've
identified from from being search
queries as uh e-commerce websites
so those define like a purchase
subcategory
on the the regular expression and the
logic is is really just
looking for you know this word is
followed by that word or uh if we're exp
experiential queries you're looking for
things like i'm alone i feel depressed i
am uh anxious
or um you know
games with friends board games with
family so so very simple things and and
that was on purpose you could probably
spend days and weeks and months trying
to uh
build really good classifiers for each
of these subcategories but we really
wanted it to be simple and intelligible
and also
optimized for precision and we're
looking at the changes um and looking at
the all of the data simultaneously
using the same logic so
we thought this was a great first step
and obviously if um for things that
we're more interested in down the line
we may move on to a more complicated
more complex way to detect uh some of
these signals
great thanks
um taking a step back uh
we all
experience that research is not
necessarily a linear process so that
involves a lot of iterations uh involves
serendipity sometimes you
kind of come across ideas that
that yesterday
you know were far from your mind but
really help you overcome some kind of
hurdle that you're you're facing
and i was just wondering if any of you
had examples related to the work you
presented
where such a thing happens where where
whether it's collaboration with other
people or
being in an environment where you can be
creative and explore ideas
helped you kind of overcome those
um i guess i can go
so uh so yeah i mean i i think you know
um certainly
uh
actually one of the hardest things about
uh this extended work from home uh has
been the
uh absence of the a lot of those
serendipitous interactions where you
talk to a coworker learn about their
work and you get an idea about how
it might actually be uh immensely
beneficial to something you could do uh
but definitely uh
in my own research um and for uh most of
people i know at msr
uh we tend to be uh extremely
collaborative exactly for this reason
that um just you know having
um having inputs and ideas from a broad
group of people can be um can can be so
powerful and if certainly for
the particular uh work i went into a bit
more detail today on uh imitation
learning
so so there is there is a question that
had been bothering me really um since
2015 when i did some previous work on
imitation learning
on you know how to simultaneously
uh
how to really improve upon the
suboptimal baseline policy well and it
wasn't until we started thinking about
combining multiple baselines we landed
on a solution concept and a method
that um
did a pretty good job on solving that
challenge as well which wasn't really
something i had
started out with an idea to solve
and you know
all the credit goes to having an amazing
creative intern who came in with a
with a very determined attitude uh
uh went through the breakthroughs
experience like many of you and uh
now works in the office next to mine so
uh definitely those interactions end up
creating a lot of value for us
okay maybe i can give a
slightly complimentary perspective as
well so as iona is mentioned in the
morning at msr we are not only kind of
collaborating with all the researchers
but we also kind of talk about many of
the problems that are out in the real
world for the different products and
services that our say partner teams are
working on like the product teams
so one of the problems that we started
out or like worked on last year was a
knowledge distillation
that typically kind of came from them
like you have these big models like bird
and then you cannot kind of
have that
latency to kind of productionize them
then what do you do about that
similarly another work on this few short
learning that also came from a similar
kind of problem perspective that you
have a lot of customer data that you
can't really look at
which is kind of compliant and user
sensitive which we call like eyes off
but you kind of can see some proxy data
which we call ison that are typically
kind of voluntary contributed right so
how do you build models and how do you
kind of mitigate the distributional
shift and all of these different kinds
of problems are kind of motivated
by existing real-life problems in the
products and services and we kind of
collaborated with both the researchers
internally and our partner teams to come
up with solutions
i just want to add one more thing to
that um which is uh for for me or for
our group i think um one of the ways for
us to be creative and thinking i think
outside of the box is to collaborate
with
um people
who are really beyond our domain of
expertise so for example we typically
work with clinicians um so we had a
psychiatrist uh psychologist that we
worked with to develop one of the mental
health applications um
we and we we work in domains of health
and well-being which means you know we
don't have the clinical experience but
we can partner with other clinical
institutions um who can bring in that
expertise that we don't have so i think
um
a lot of those collaborations and and
looking seeking outside of your group
for expertise that you don't have i
think it's really valuable
great examples thanks
um question for
um deborah
i'm aware that you've done some work
looking at kind of architecture search
in the context of pipelines for
interactive systems could you explain a
little more about that because i think
that's a really nice example of kind of
interdisciplinary or cross-disciplinary
engagement thinking about um
you know the real-time systems and how
they might leverage some of what you've
been doing
oh absolutely yeah um that's a wonderful
question so
that actually is also ties into the
previous question you just had um the
the whole problem definition of okay let
me first actually give a little bit of
the problem so the problem often is that
we have systems meaning we are a
software company the world runs on
software in many ways right now and and
we have this incredibly complicated
software pipelines not just machine
learning pipelines but generic software
pipelines right and and ask anybody who
has done anything with regards to
machine learning in a real world
software
production pipeline they will tell you
that the machine learning bit of it is
actually the really minor part of it
right the entire pipeline and everything
else that it fits into matters and so
for example
imagine you get a query and the query
has to go through a lot of like you know
steps and components and then what
decision you make at each component
really matters for the downstream
component for example like you know if
you have a face recognition module uh
which then which receives the image it
takes finds where the most likely faces
are sends it to let's say a face
landmark detection module and then which
processes it and then maybe it may send
it to an effective uh uh
like you know uh sentiment detection
module and so on and so forth so every
decision that is getting made
by a previous component has uh
repercussions for what the uh downstream
components see so this so we saw this
like you know that this general this
abstracted output
problem as pipeline optimization problem
where this this can
happen for anything not even just
machine learning pipelines but in
general software engineers
software engineering pipelines so uh
[Laughter]
uh which is this wonderful platform for
writing this
like
uh
oh
do sequential decisions
parameters
foreign
is
what is that
wonderful part of working at msr
great example and just to wrap up one
final question segwaying from that so
pavel had a question um
the the real benefit of removing the
burden of low-level model tuning using
architecture search
but do you think that these methods
would
will be able to do the hardest things
that that humans currently do think
things like
discover batch norm is a very useful
thing to do or different types of
activation functions um
create a transformer
you know
will we get there or is that something
that always will need a human to kind of
develop those insights
well uh so uh i'm glad that that's a
wonderful question because there's
actually actively in the community
papers coming out where people are
designing like you know hey if i design
a search space where it which admits
let's say like you know 10 to the power
18 different
activation functions can be realized or
you could even think of this as a
continuous parameterization of an entire
family of activation functions
and you want to figure out like you know
which activation function the network
should use automatically in which part
of the network right and as it is
searching for it should not only search
for
let's say what layer types to put in but
it should also automatically search for
what activation functions you should put
in now uh
obviously this this comes with a caveat
right like you know you are you are
expanding the search space the search
space becomes bigger and bigger and and
there's this trade-off between how
expressive and general i want to make
the search space and hope that like you
know really interesting things will fall
out in reasonable compute time um uh
where reasonable may mean like let's say
one week on a
eight gpu machine and an unreasonable
will vary from um uh what is the
application and how much money you have
for compute um
but at the same time you are starting to
see like you know uh for example this
work finding like very interesting new
kinds of activation functions
which we would not have found before by
hand or at least item like unless you
uh maybe we would have like you know
it's hard to do counterfactuals here but
but we are definitely finding computers
are finding very interesting activation
functions now uh talking about things
like transformers or batch normalization
which you can think as a little bit
higher level uh concepts um one thing
that people are finding is that uh
there's
that hey what if i take a spa
architecture space in which transform
transformers is a dot right like self
attention is is is a particular point in
that architecture space uh would self
attention emerge right like and would
like maybe like hybrids of how much self
attention you need combined with how
many encoders and decoders you need
would all of those things automatically
emerge instead of us like you know
trying things out uh by hand right like
and if you look at transformer paper or
bird paper at least when i look at it
and i'm not even like you know in the
deep learning uh things as much it's
always i'm always scratching my head why
is it six encoders why is it six
decoders why is this connected there
what happens if i connect this there and
to me a lot of these like you know
higher level building blocks we can bias
the search space right like we can take
the search space but instead of us
trying to decide how many decoders
encoders there are let a computer figure
it out right like why should we humans
do all this tedious work of typing
things in in a configuration file so
um i think
and bigger changes will come about like
hopefully we will discover new families
of transformers we haven't yet
great thank you
um so that brings us the end of this
session thanks once again to all the
speakers for your great presentations
and this q a
we now have an hour-long break and we'll
be back at uh
1 p.m
pacific time
and we'll have another fireside chat
directly followed by the poster session
so
um grab grab a break
some food
and we'll be back with you at 1pm
thanks